i complied i put it on after they asked
me to
isn't it isn't it policy that he can
wear his mat he can take off his mask
here you go say that he put his mask on
he took it off when he started eating
the nuts
that was it i was sitting right here so
it's not a it's not a publicity
son it's trying to make you follow
policy
indiscriminately and impartially
okay so do you follow your policy
indiscriminately and impartially or do
you just do this for people whose
message you don't like
all right we're doing something on the
fly today uh late last night i was
scanning twitter why am i scanning
twitter i don't know but i was scanning
twitter
and i saw a video that started going
viral of
a young black man who was on a southwest
flight
and being kicked off the flight
and it seemed to have something to do
with the fact that he was wearing a
trump 2020 mask
and he had a black voices for trump hat
and there was
a supervisor from southwest kicking him
off the plane there was a woman
narrating it and a couple other
people that got involved it didn't sound
like he did anything wrong because you
obviously are allowed to take your mask
down when you're when you're eating or
drinking
uh thanks to the sleuths on the internet
we have been able to locate that guy
philip nadiphon and uh his friend his
co-worker actually
uh who filmed the whole thing chris ann
hall it turns out that chris ann hall
is a constitutional expert and they were
traveling the country teaching the
constitution
and philip was doing some video work for
her so it's sort of a perfect fit on a
couple fronts so what we're going to do
right now
is we're going to play most of the two
videos
that went viral so that you can see the
context of what happened
and i should just note that i did before
we
play the interview i did talk to them
for a minute or two before
and i have assurances from them that
nothing happened
outside of the video that would uh
imply that they were trying to get
publicity or that this was staged
or anything else so we're going to play
the viral videos
and then we're going to go into my
interview with philip and chris anne
hall and i just want to say one other
thing which is that the reason that i
wanted to do this
is that this is a a young black man who
was just kicked off a flight
in effect for no reason and we certainly
know
that if he didn't have a trump uh mask
or a black voices for trump hat
that this is the type of this type of
story as he was kicked off by a white
supervisor
that the media would love and this would
be being played everywhere and this
would be the head of cnn
and celebrities and democratic
politicians would be telling you this
should
prove systemic racism and the rest of it
but because he is a trump supporter
you're going to see some clips of this
on youtube
and you'll see some clips of it on
twitter but it won't make it
to mainstream it just won't mark my
words as i'm taping this right now it's
about 8 a.m
uh it's not even 8 a.m here in los
angeles and i'm willing to take the risk
that this thing is not going to be on
msnbc or cnn today
unless we force the issue so that's what
i'm trying to do here
because i think it's important it's
important to see because the people that
will tell you that everything is racist
seem to only see racism when it fits
their narrative
so without further ado here's the
original viral video
and then my interview with phillip and
chris anne
they said if i'm actively eating
so we're not allowed to eat with our
masks off is that what you're saying
am i not allowed to up
that he can wear his mat he can take off
his mask
no i'm sorry i'm his legal counsel is it
not
your policy that he can wear him take
off his mask
what am i going to do
but the thing about it is right now if
you're not going on this airtime
so you're just going on here saying
violating southwest policy then right
what am i supposed
can you tell us the policy that prevents
him from taking his mask off while he's
eating please
i was not here for present the crew has
denied okay but you're seeing him with
eating so please tell me the policy tell
the crew to tell me the policy
that says he cannot eat with his mask
off right now
or i'll call the police
it's the hat it's the hat and the mask
it's not the eating
i fly three times a week here's the deal
i haven't really done anything but
you're being denied boarding by the crew
the crew is not going to take it
so can you clarify for us are we not
allowed to take our masks off to eat on
this plane
can you please clarify are we are not
allowed to take our masks off to eat on
this plane or not listen to the flight
crew and follow their instructions
so are you going to tell us that we can
take our masks off
to eat on the plate see
he did cooperate
he put his mask on he took it off when
he started eating the nuts
that was it i was sitting right here so
can we just take the puzzle
do you follow your policy
indiscriminately and impartially or do
you just do this for people whose
message you don't like
all right and joining me right now are
the two people in that video the guy who
dared to eat
on an airplane philip nadifan and the
woman who filmed the whole thing chris
ann hall guys i expect you're gonna have
a bit of a crazy day thanks for joining
me so early
thank you thank you for having us on
okay so
look i don't want to fall into a trap
here and we all know how video can be
edited and things
could have happened beforehand and
everything you guys before we started we
talked for just 20 seconds you guys gave
me your word that
philip you were not doing anything you
weren't supposed to be doing
and all that so before we do anything
else can you guys just tell me
what flight you were on why you were
going somewhere and how do you know each
other let's just start off
with the basics we were flying
from tampa florida on southwest airlines
our final destination
was going to be amarillo but we had a
layover in dallas
and i'm a constitutional attorney which
kind of helps us a little bit in this
and i'm a constitutional educator
traveling around the country
teaching the constitution so philip and
i were on our way
to one of my constitutional training
events in
oklahoma city and philip was coming to
film the event
and we were there with my husband and my
son it's a whole
team that we have to to make this
constitution training happen
and there really isn't much more to the
story than what you see
on the video because we hadn't even
pulled away from the gate yet
okay so philip you had you dared to have
a trump 2020 mask and
what what were the exact words on your
hat or you've got the hat there why
don't you show people that
yeah i have the hat it was uh black
voices for trump
i'm an african-american just supporting
the
trump administration and then my truck
uh mass
trump 2020 make america great again and
that's
that's basically all that singled me out
basically the the whole flight i mean i
mean i mean
for the duration of the time that i was
on the flight yeah there was no other
reason for
them to even point me out except the
fact that i was supporting black voices
for trump
or you know trump 2020 yeah so did the
flight attendant give you any warning
before
what we see in the video there did they
tell you how you're supposed to eat i
mean i know we've all got these crazy
rules
what were you eating what were you doing
right i was actually eating a bag of
trail mix
and uh the flight attendant and a cup of
coffee as well i even have a video of
myself you know drinking a cup of coffee
and then
putting the mask back on as they
required over the nose
which is the only warning that they even
told me was to put the mask over the
nose
not under the nose so that was the only
warning that i received from anybody and
the flight attendant himself was
hispanic
so you know i i wasn't really expecting
any any
drama anything that was going to happen
and
prior to that nothing else led up to the
fact that they were going to refuse my
service
except the fact that i was i had this
mask on
i have this on and i was just eating a
bag of trail mix
yeah so when the flight attendant came
up to you
did he immediately is what we see in the
video exactly what happened i mean did
he immediately say you have to get off
the plane
that was actually the supervisor so the
flight attendant
never came back uh he just went
and apparently went to get went
and complained to the pilot the pilot
called the supervisor the supervisor is
the one that you actually see on camera
and so the supervisor is telling him
uh the flight attendant has told me
you're refusing to wear your mask you're
refusing to comply with our policy
and you now have to leave the plane
and so the late even the lady in the
video that i took the lady behind us
said look he's complying he just took it
off
to eat and there were other people on
the plane who weren't wearing their
masks that we're eating
we you can look around you can even see
it in the video and and
the flight attendant said nothing to
those people yeah
i mean just from our couple minutes here
philip it's pretty obvious to me this is
not like some play for attention
or or anything and anything like that
can you tell me a little bit this is
sort of an offshoot but can you just
tell me a little bit about
uh why you're why you're supporting the
president and
and what black voices for trump means to
you i don't know if you guys are
familiar with my show at all but i've
had a lot of people on
that that share that sentiment from the
black community and and i think
something really
really incredible is happening right now
i'm just curious your thoughts on that
absolutely and i mean i i grew up in a
uh multicultural home my mom's
originally from pennsylvania my dad's
originally from nigeria so
uh as a you know black american
i support president trump because he is
obviously he's for pro-life
which i'm about you know he he's doing
more for the black community i mean
that's the
biggest problem that we're actually
having in our inner cities and our inner
communities
is the the death of you know unborn
babies there's the
you know the the job joblessness and
before the whole covet you know thing
transpired we had the lowest
unemployment rate
that has that we've ever seen i saw
people getting jobs that i never even
thought they would you know
because they you know i just didn't
expect them to you know to really take
on and are actually starting businesses
and then trump also putting in place the
opportunity zones with
100 100 billion dollars into the inner
cities for opportunity zones to build
the community
that kind of stuff is unprecedented and
i haven't seen it in my lifetime
a president that's undergo undergone
such scrutiny
for helping the black community and
calling him a racist is kind of like
does it make sense to me because he's
doing more for the black community than
any president
prior even president obama yeah i'm
guessing
i'm guessing you've probably gotten a
little hate for the hat in the mask
before right
yeah definitely uh not always the
most pleasant interactions but i mean
you know what was interesting as philip
was we were
walking through the tampa airport philip
had his mask
and his hat on the whole time and we got
nothing but support people would come up
to us and
and talk to him and ask us what we were
doing and why we were traveling and ask
him about his hat and
right it was the overwhelming popular
support of the people it's just the
the mainstream media seems to be bent on
creating a narrative to simply create a
reality
rather than simply describe the reality
america is actually experiencing
yeah believe me i hear you i i stumbled
upon a trump rally in la of all places
the other day i just happened to be
going down the street and there was a
trump rally and guess what there were
black people white people gay people
straight people
latino people and and nobody cared all
right so since you are a
uh constitutional lawyer uh i suspect
there's gonna be some
some legal action on the way am i am i
mistaken
we're going to start off by writing a
nice letter
we're going to give southwest the
opportunity
to do the right thing i am although i am
a constitutional lawyer
i am not you know i don't have a trigger
finger so i don't
go around and sue everybody i want
everybody to have the opportunity
to make things whole without entering
into
the field of litigation i'd like to see
an amicable relationship
i have personally been flying southwest
for
10 over 10 years and for me their
customer service has been impeccable
and so i don't i want to know as a
customer that this is
not the view of south west that this is
just
some flight attendant that got upset or
triggered and is letting his own bias
override his professionalism so i want
and they have the
opportunity to make us whole in that
right
all right i'm glad to hear that because
i think you know people see these videos
and they automatically think oh
something must have happened right
before or these guys are just trying to
get into a lawsuit and
and it genuinely doesn't sound that way
with you guys philip you know i find
that there's moments over the last
couple years where i've interviewed
somebody where it's like oh
they're about to to step into something
much bigger if they want it
if you were uh introduced to candace
owens and brandon tatum and larry elder
and all those guys
do you want a louder voice in that black
voices for trump movement because
uh i know a guy
well i i'm i'm all about the
constitution that's why i'm
actually traveling this with miss
christine hall i'm about you know
the values that america upholds the
freedom that we have here so
if there was any platform that i was
ever introduced to
do that i would obviously take that only
because
i do believe that you know not just
trump and anybody
that believes in this country and
believes in freedom i think that
that that should be voiced from every
single person
so yeah all right well let me uh let me
see what i could do
i i might be able to i might be able to
make something happen there
all right well i know you guys you guys
have a hectic day of uh teaching people
about the constitution which is another
thing dear to my heart so i'm gonna let
you get to it
i thank you guys for taking the time
this morning and good luck with
everything and you know if you need to
get the message out further you know how
to get me
thank you sir awesome if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell